okay
for people joining this live stream this
is a
language completeness and consistency
meeting
looking at features of language um
and we have a variety of topics today
let's see what's first
excluded and presumably included
contexts
okay change full definition so it
doesn't recursively pull in internal
contexts
so things like save definitions um
are making use of full definitions that
a true statement or do they have their
own way of doing this
that is a true statement
there may be things like
there may be there may be a few
functions that are
sort of rolling their own but for the
most part they either use full
definition or it's somewhat
more uh completely complete friend the
language
extended full definition
okay but so something like cloud deploy
what does it do that's the second case
it's a language
extended full definition okay and an
extended full definition avoids internal
context so it doesn't
it does okay
so where do we think full definition is
getting used is it getting used by
people's code or is it getting used by
people when they just do things at top
level
um well save uses full definition
um and manipulate with save definitions
uses full definition okay
so i mean the main issue is i mean there
are potentially
look there are potentially all kinds of
horrifying bugs associated with changing
you know
what kinds of definitions get pulled in
right which is why we we
did it you know we we made that right we
backed it out of 12
2 because you thought we didn't have
enough testing time and now we put it
back in about a month ago for 12
30. okay fine all right so look
let me make another comment i mean this
whole question about what's savorable
what's internal
what's not what should be exposed what
shouldn't
you know in a sense this has become a
very confused thing
because you know we have a completely
modifiable system
right so people can modify anything so
it's like well what's
you know at what point okay well they
can't modify
list because it's no fair enough but
okay
okay but but you know where is the
moment
of you know where is the bedrock so to
speak
where do they in other words i guess the
question is and it gets even more
extreme
let's imagine a world in which there was
a certain init.m bundle
effectively where there was a certain
initialization bundle that people had
and so somebody says well i know you
have this initialization bundle
so i don't need to send you these
definitions i only need to send you
these definitions that are kind of
the froth on top so to speak you see
what i'm saying
i mean i'm kind of wondering whether
there's a way of saying whether there's
a mechanism
in the system where we say okay
initialization is over
at this moment we will tag every
definition that's been made and those
definitions
won't be ever transmitted in a in a
full definition z-type way and in other
words where we actively tag
things at some moment during
initialization
and if you have a different sort of
bedrock then
you know then different things will be
sent over comments
i'm not sure if you're suggesting i mean
i don't
i don't see how that could be made
customizable right i mean we do
i mean this thing does essentially run
at a certain point in the initialization
i forget the customizability because i'm
realizing that
that my idea doesn't make sense because
it's not a time-based thing because it
could be that a pac-lick gets loaded
after a paclet gets loaded that sprays a
bunch of internal context things into
the system
and that happens long after
initialization right so
so the issue is really look the issue is
really
what is underground and what is not
and when a packet is loaded yeah here's
a good question
when a packet is loaded does it have any
way of saying
i'm a subterranean paclet or does it
just
you know or is it all very you know
egalitarian whether basically
the paclet i bet that there is no way of
it saying i'm a subterranean paclet
i shouldn't be added to auto completes
etc etc etc right uh
there isn't but there there's no reason
why we couldn't add such a thing
no i agree but so maybe what we want to
do
and and in fact one of the uh i mean
one of the things that we i mean i guess
it's not
explicitly listed here uh but
one of the the things we we agreed that
we're going to do assuming
we can get todd's attention long enough
is to add a way where
paclets can declare their themselves as
subterranean so that when they're loaded
they're automatically
added to this uh to this list of
internal contexts
okay so let's talk about what this means
so
what we're defining right now is one
sort of standard
for are you below ground or above ground
and below ground means
that full definitions won't reach that
low
it'll just it will never pick you up
well by default it will not pick you up
okay fair enough the now
the question is you know is there only
one one
you know sea level or something here or
do we want
i mean in other words
yeah so you're saying since
okay things which we can reasonably
obvious assume
will exist or be autoloaded on
any other system of the same version
number any other wolfram language
installation with the same version
number
those are things that there's no reason
for this full definitions by default to
pick up
correct okay so
i would argue
yeah i mean i think this is what we
should do we should have some kind of
tagging
um of contexts that
you know we should have some way of
saying
this context is intended to be
okay now i know they're going to be some
other issues here but but first step is
this context is um
yeah it should be added i mean we have a
list right it's
if you want to see it it's uh i think
it's language backtick
internal context or dollar internal
context something like that
and and so you can see what the current
list is
um and uh
i mean but so maybe what we should call
it
is you know dollar system context or
something
and it's a big list that just gets
accumulated
maybe it needs a name which is um
well what was the thing you said it was
right now it's
language backtech and i think it's
internal context it might be dollar
internal contexts
um that's a good name for it by the way
why is it oh it stays blue that's
interesting
okay so this is a a list that has been
made
sort of from the outside of contexts
that are okay
so when a when a packet is loaded as a
system packet
is it loaded in any different way than
any other packet is loaded
no it's do we know it's a system z load
it's an internal load
or is it just you know it's a packet
install like any other pacline install
uh well i think todd would be better
able to answer that question but
there there is uh there is a step
of of sort of scanning
the the the sort of known paclets
in the layout that happens at
initialization time
and so those are and that's used in so a
lot of these are coming from paclets
that
are sort of known at sort of an
early stage uh okay but every paclet
that might be a system paclet
is in the source control system right
there's no other source for them is that
true or is that not true
um i suppose
probably oh actually that's not true
because there are
sometimes we create one off bug fix
backlits
that uh okay but so what i'm going to
suggest
is that maybe we should have an idiom
for every system paclet
that it has some call at the beginning
of it yes that that's on the tattoo list
already stephen as i've already said
okay fine fine well so then
then what you're saying is that this
thing dollar internal contexts
right so when you say excluded context
goes to automatic which is the default
then these contacts and their
sub-contexts
are are not sucked in so if you
say full definition explicitly of a
symbol in this context
then you'll get its definition just like
you always would but if you happen
to you know use some symbol that happens
to reference one of these symbols
it won't be sort of recursively sucked
in
um in that sense okay well that sounds
pretty good to me
i mean then then how is that going to
connect to the autocomplete system for
example
um well at the present time it doesn't
although i suppose it could be made
yeah because i mean that's they are
constantly whitelisting
blacklisting etc they shouldn't be they
should get their list from this
and that that thing that sucks in a new
context
should send a message to the front end
saying hello there's a new one
well so so right now one of the things
on this list is system which is
sort of a question okay we need a new
question
yeah we need to talk about that okay so
but i want to be clear
this is a way to solve the stupid
problem of adding crazy things to the
autocompletes
probably i'm not willing to commit to
that
fine but but that's what i'm suggesting
so if that isn't the case somebody can
tell me about it in a different meeting
right um okay so let's talk about system
right and lo
and in particular i think it's probably
worth looking at the example to
understand sort of
uh yeah
what's x come to oh that was twelve
point two
that's what you were oh oh sorry that
yes that that that was supposed to
that is undoubtedly a typo yes
what the heck is this and 12-2
the flat of f must be because i i had a
straight definition of
uh a flat but the rest of it
is is perfectly accurate because
you don't have a definition right the
first input
there isn't a definition for g it's a
definition for derivative of one of
g and f references derivative of one of
g
right so the problem here is that those
attributes
are kind of ugly to see in 12 2 because
it's like well yeah
of course it has that attribute that's
what it was originally had
so again this is one of these questions
about when
you know it's like this piece of the
down values
was part of the you know the natural
state of things the bedrock
this piece of the down values or in this
case
uh what are these sub-values something
attributes
no no this i'm saying here well that
that
is no that is a user defined definitely
i know that but what is it it's a it's a
is it a is it an up value on g or what
is it
no it's a it's a it's a uh
it's a value on derivative okay fine
all right so what i'm saying is this
imagine
that the down value list or the sub
value list
had tagging in it right
imagine that that list actually
said this was done as part of an
initialization packet
so for example this might be set as part
of his initialization backlight
well that's uh surely done in the c code
okay fine but then then there could be a
a way
in which things that are added to a
system context symbol
that were you know foreign
editions not seen not yet seen
when where they're known to be user
editions get tagged in some way in the
down value sub-value
up value list and yeah what i'm saying
i see what you're saying i'm not sure
how that that is remotely possible
why why so i'm going to make this
suggestion about how it would right
because by that
by the time we we've created the list of
of things
we've already right we're already in
normal
evaluation by basically i mean we're
reading
an init dot m essentially but
we're we're in normal evaluation we're
past all of the kernels
initialization stages and for example
if it's if it's loading right suppose
you have an auto load
or suppose you have something defined in
startup right so that's not
known at the time until you start using
right
say you're using grad right right now if
you look at own values of grad
assuming you haven't used it before
right it has some
bizarro own value that that
is tells it to auto load when it's
called right so right now
after you've you're already in your
interactive session
it doesn't have any down values it will
only have down values after you use it
so how do you expect us to mark the
value
wait wait a second it only has down
values after you use it
okay right and so you're saying
those values you don't want to mark as
user added
the values in other words if i just type
grad of you know
x squared comma x or something okay
you need a list around it otherwise it's
uh oh yeah right
um okay anyway but it doesn't matter but
now the grad is probably auto loaded and
down
the end values of ground is nothing
correct
why is it why is it a null list oh it's
own value sorry
yeah right um okay
so
what i'm saying is okay and i'm not
telling you how to implement it yet
what i'm saying is if there was a thing
defined by an assignment
right
okay so we have to know it's like dollar
evaluation environment
right there's a there's a notion of
is this a user god it reminds me of the
very earliest computers of user
space well you know all these interrupt
levels and so on
user level system level et cetera et
cetera et cetera
if it is a user level thing that's
happening
right then it gets tagged and we have to
know are we operating in an evaluation
environment that is a user level
evaluation environment or a system level
evaluation environment
that would be the distinction now
the definition of a user level
evaluation environment
is presumably it's
not i mean it's a little tricky but it's
not a system auto i mean it has to be
thought about but let's imagine
that i mean we can certainly expect to
tag that what is a user level evaluation
environment
and then the idea would be to if you're
at a user level evaluation environment
to look at when you are setting a down
value
of a system symbol for example to
basically tag that user level
down value so that you know
oh it's a system symbol we only want to
save by default the things which are
tagged user level
editions
see what i'm saying yes i don't think
this is crazy
i mean i think that that what we would
want yeah i really don't think this is
crazy i think this is kind of the
if we did that then i believe these
problems kind of go away then
then you know because what we're doing
is anything that isn't part of the
system
we want to be able to full definition
pull out with full definitions by
default
so okay that's my suggestion here maybe
we should think about this
and move on for now is there is anything
obviously stupid about this i mean
obviously it's got it there's a lot of
tentacles with attributes and god knows
what else
um anybody else i mean i don't know
whether the right people are in this
meeting to really comment on this
further
yeah i'm sure i don't have anything
sensible to say but exactly that's what
worries me in the tentacles because
for example i'm evaluating um
one of brett's plot functions and so
obviously that's a system thing
except that i've provided an evaluation
monitor
or something like that and so now it's
calling out back outs to user level code
and so yeah so right so
so so i i suspect it's solvable but
you know but the whole point is that the
plot function itself
is you're saying if something is you're
saying
in the kind of the layers of oh you've
got a user level function
that is making a system level call to
download a packet
i don't think that paclet download
itself makes the user level call
not until that's returned is there a
user level call right
right but it means right it means that
that
everything has to be very careful about
knowing exactly what it is
well i agree but the choice is right now
we're just splaffering all over the
place
yeah right so so you know maybe the
octopus still has a little tiny piece of
a tentacle hanging out of the jar
but let's at least get the main octopus
in the jar
well
i i i guess my counter to this is right
we've been
using i guess we haven't had included
context but we've
been using excluded context successfully
and and yeah
definition for several versions and so i
don't know why you want to throw away
something that that because i think this
is a better solution i think this is a
thing that has been an issue for a long
time
and we keep on having different versions
of it we have versions let me give you
other examples of where this shows up
auto completes stack showing the stack
i don't this won't help with auto
completes
yes it will oh no no no talking about
whether it has system level
no no that won't that one that won't
help that won't help i agree
i agree it will help only in the only i
mean this will do more
the current pro you know uh this thing
which was i mean which you did approve
i mean it's not like i know this out of
nowhere yeah i'm aware i know i've
just been watching how many different
tentacles this thing has and i think
it's time
to actually go octopus hunting so to
speak instead of just
trying to patch you know put little you
know masks on different tentacles
i think we've got to get the whole
octopus and put it in the jar
or whatever you do with octopus all
right well i'm i'm not going to do that
i i mean i don't know if who you can
find to do that but i'm not going to do
that
okay well that let's have the right
people in the meeting and let's figure
out what to do
this isn't the right people well
it's not the right people i mean it's
not the right people this isn't a this
is not a front-end
you know cloud type problem
it is on that end the solution might be
deep in the kernel is what we're saying
yes
do you think you have another solution
because i don't think you're going to
find another solution i think by
definition
the thing i'm talking about is the only
ultimate solution that's going to work
any other solution isn't yet another
hack now you know
is it the right thing to put in a
different slightly different hack for a
version or two perhaps
do you think you have another solution
that's actually a solution
well i i don't think your solution is
the solution
okay just okay fine i think my solution
is at least
has the mechanism to make a solution
even if
that we all agree that it has many
tentacles and they'll be it'll be
complicated to to
you know capture all of them
but okay is there some particular
proposal that you have
that we should look at perhaps as an
interim solution
well it's it's it's it's exactly
you know doing the thing we have been
doing for several versions and
and making it more widely usable
which is and then the question is is
really about system
which is okay but i'm telling you system
look
and and the thing that you're saying
that we've been doing for multiple
versions with different contexts
is really not that different from what i
was saying to do with different contexts
i think those are those are very similar
i mean it's just a question of how we
manage that
in the source code and so on the stuff
with system do you have a solution to
that or not
well what what do you think is the issue
with system
well that that there are things that are
being added
as as uh sub values and things like that
to system symbols um i mean and there
are things that
for example changing so so the symbols
that will be pulled in
right from sys if if we don't consider
sys
right so anything any system symbol
which is protected
will be ignored because full definition
does not pull in things
which are protected irrespective of
context that's how it's been documented
and that's how it's operated since
version 102. okay so it's precisely
those system symbols which are not
protected
which is you know derivative subscript
you know i suppose dollar assumptions
and so and so my so my my solution is
we we we don't exclude those because
if there's anything non-trivial there
it's been added by the user
and okay what about dollar context path
um
[Music]
which is not protected do we actually
want to
move that over or not
i don't know i mean i'm not sure about
that one okay so what am i saying
so the choice is okay can we crispen up
what
i mean i think the solution that i'm
proposing is a
is a good forward-looking solution now i
might be wrong
but that's what i think now you're
proposing basically
anything that isn't protected go and
pick it up
is that correct anything in in system
in system yes that's what i'm talking
about correct
so that would include time zone and
um maybe
see those are tentacles which would also
be tentacles in my description
as well i mean it's not obvious whether
that
uh time so that the dollar time zone is
not picked up
uh why uh oh hold on i'm i'm in
no i'm i'm in the correct version
and the reason is
[Music]
uh maybe it's protected no it's not
um
just don't think it does can't you set
the time zone
dollar language for example
[Music]
um
i think this is a quite complicated
issue and i think we probably need a
larger group of people to talk it
through
all right i think that that but i think
the proposal that i'm making
i you know is anybody here interested in
the proposal that i'm making or is
everybody
kind of um uh do we need to find
somebody else to champion that proposal
or does everybody do other people other
than a tie just think it's a bad idea
it seems like a very
sort of heavy weapon in my opinion i
mean maybe it's necessary and it it
doesn't it's a difficult problem
that's the thing it's a difficult
problem it is a difficult thing to say
in a system
where everything is modifiable or lots
of things are modifiable
what should we count as being added by
the user
yeah that's what i'm still wondering is
there no better way or
other way to to define what we actually
expect to be change
well there's another possibility if we
had another possibility of another
attribute
we could have an attribute that says um
no it's not even going to work i mean
you know the things where there is i i
don't know it right now but i bet there
are things
where some down values are system added
by the system and some down values are
added by the user
is that correct because if that's
correct we're toast here
like on how how exactly wanna be right
if
we're saying in that case it would be
fine to just send it
along still yeah i don't know i don't
know whether that causes trouble
i i don't know maybe it never causes
trouble to send like the attributes of
derivative along i don't know maybe that
never maybe we shouldn't worry about it
because it doesn't cause trouble
right i don't think it causes trouble
right because it's just reaffirming what
it already
does already has no i understand
which i mean and right and the real
problem we're trying to avoid is when
you're going to pick up you know 10
megabytes
of of uh
you know machine learning down values
because
one of them wasn't protected and was
somehow referenced
yes
you know that that's a real problem for
for the cloud and sort of
how how jan sicked me on this problem in
the first place
right ethan observes just technically
whatever the user hadn't modified next
topic
yeah that's that's what i've been trying
to do here um
all right i think we should look at this
proposal of mine more carefully with a
larger set of people
figure out what tentacles it has i know
it will have tentacles someone like
roman will be a good person to have a
think through that proposal
especially since he's worked on
initializations type stuff
okay name and scope of imported object
right i just i just don't understand why
you have
imported object i mean it's it's it's
it's binary blob with metadata so
so i i don't understand why it's called
important
object the fact that it was imported
seems completely irrelevant
to the fact okay so here's the idea
here's the idea just like in
external evaluate we have the notion of
an external object
and an external function an external
object
is a thing which is a handle to
something completely outside our system
right it's not really a handle it's
[Music]
it's literally a bite array or several
byte arrays
of stuff but it's a pointer it's a
pointer to something in the address
space of an external program
no it's not not imported objects i'm
sorry i
i that wasn't what i was talking about i
just said external object
oh external object yes i was trying to
give you some context
okay external object is
a pointer to something in the address
space of an external program
okay it is something that we know
nothing about
however we can pass that thing back
to that external program and it will say
thank you very much i understand this
you see what i'm saying yep
okay so the idea of imported object
is something similar that is we got a
blob of
stuff from a pem file let's say
we don't know what it is sure we do it
we know it's
just no no no in general we don't know
what it is
okay in general we don't know what it
means we don't know what it is
we want some metadata associated with it
that says
it came from a pem file it was this and
that and the other
but here it is it's just a blob let me
give you an example of something we used
to do which we don't do anymore
which is raw postscript inside graphics
okay we can't interpret it we don't know
what it is
but we know it's postscript okay
so what this is it's something that we
can do nothing with
except possibly as some kind of
you know analytical hackery of looking
at the byte array and seeing how many
nulls it has or something like that but
fundamentally we don't know how to
import it we cannot turn it into
something meaningful in our language as
far as we're concerned it's an opaque
blob of bits okay we can serialize the
bits right
oh yeah we can serialize the best
problem and i think that's that's an
important distinction to other
objects perhaps that well we can always
serialize the bits i mean we can always
serialize the object
look an external object is not
meaningfully serializable
it is serializable on that you know it's
only it only means something
if you're connected to the same external
thing
that it refers to an imported object
is in our system as a bag of bits
but we know nothing about what that bag
of bits means
other than what the metadata of imported
object tells us
and notice it's not just a byte array
because it has metadata
and it's very important that it has
metadata
right so the the idea
is i mean right now we're using this for
pem files
um i think that we should be using it
for things like uh cad formats where we
can't import everything in the format
right it's not it's not true that we
know some and no we don't know anything
about it it has a content property that
you know converts it to various things
it converts it into a public key
and digital signatures no no no no no no
no no no
general to pem file the general pen file
is no problem
the general look there are plenty of
things that we can read and pen files
okay this is for the bits that get left
over that we
can't read okay this is for let me give
you an example
okay let me give you an example let's
say we're reading in a piece of
of of 3d imagery data okay
and the format that it comes in from is
fancy movie making format okay
we can read the basic geometry but then
right in the middle of that
is a shader commands to a particular gpu
we can't read that there's nothing we
can do with it
it's gpu code it's you know it's
something weird and external
however we don't want to just throw away
that gpu code
we want to keep it because when we send
this thing back out again
after we've modified the geometry we
might very well want to say okay here
you are
i'm handing you back that gpu code be
happy you can you know what it means
we don't know what it means but you the
external program do know what it means
that's the point that's a better example
than the pen file one
which maybe is confusing because the
point is that it's the hard bits
that we can't interpret but we want to
store
because we might want to feed them back
out to the external program
but what you pass back is still the
whole data it's not just a handle on the
data that's correct
it's the whole thing
i quite like the name imported object
for this i don't really see why
it's you know it's an opaque thing it
has been imported
we have it i just don't know that the
fact that it's important
is is relevant
well okay the reason i'm saying is that
that i want to give the sense that it is
a thing from the
it is an alien thing it's an imported
species it's a
invasive species no it's a it's a it's a
thing coming from the outside
i i mean i don't know what uh you know
it's shoddy can shoddy comment right
so so here so so open the the ref page
for imported object
right now copy out that copy out that
blob
in the first example just a blob
which just this thing here yep okay
right and do evaluate that of
content of the string content
right right how's that a blob we know
nothing about
that's kind of dumb okay that's not what
this was intended for
um well this is an extension
just for pem i guess they decided that
they could at least turn this thing into
an association even if we don't want a
you know fully fledged wrapper for that
type of content
there's also a raw content key which is
what this was supposed to be
raw content is required content isn't
yeah this is silly i i completely agree
with you
ty this is silly right this is a fine
imported thing it has nothing to do with
you know it doesn't need to be wrapped
up in an imported object
doesn't make any sense
i mean i'm not certain that this
contains all of the contents of the raw
content though we'd have to ask uh
okay but then it's wrong then then this
is wrong then this should be called
metadata or something because
calling this content is just silly right
i mean in in um
i i have no opinion about i mean this
says 597 bytes i don't know how big the
other one is
but yeah that's wrong okay i can see why
you're confused now
okay what this should be i don't know
what the raw content piece is supposed
to be
this can say you know imported object
and it might give a little bit of
metadata information here
but then as you know and maybe if you if
you do properties it'll tell you what
are the known properties of the imported
object
so byte count so i presume byte count
and
raw content and probably original format
that will are probably required i would
say that things like
you know we could have things like i
don't know
um which are essentially metadata pieces
that we are able to see
right take my example of the gpu shader
okay we might be able to say this is
intended for nvidia blah blah blah
gpu and we might even be able to say
you know i don't know if it's a bunch of
byte codes for the nvidia
device there's not going to be anything
useful we can say about it
but i agree by the time it's exposable
as a bunch of you know as
a meaningful association what the heck
are we doing packaging up
an imported object an imported object is
intended to be
okay there may be a different thing i
don't know we do we have anybody who
knows about specifically about the pen
file case
if we don't we don't have the right
people here uh
right well it's because i mean that
would be uh daria who
who was in the wrong time zone zone
okay um
okay david on our live stream is saying
um
uh raw content appears to contain the
entire pen file
yeah that that's that's the right thing
and nick is pointing out would an
imported javascript from a web page be a
good example for an imported object yes
it doesn't contain the entire file it
contains just the chunk of the file that
we couldn't import
fine well that's what but i mean
again if we had something that for
instance makes
you know that's supposed to turn a web
page into a notebook
and there's a piece of the webpage
that's javascript this will be a good
thing to use to represent that
it's something a little confused i mean
i think it's good to have that concept
but i still understand
why it's called an object if it's not
handled but really the whole thing
because we we're we are we're not using
object to mean handle in all cases we
we have generalized that notion and we
don't it doesn't mean a handle
yeah i mean i think imported data might
be
a better name but it's not necessarily
data that will be very confusing
i might be wrong about this but to me
content almost looks like
the just a sporadic amount of metadata
that we were able to interpret from that
chunk of well it could be
in that case we should say then it's
just the wrong property name
content is the wrong property name
then it should be but then the question
is
if we have this called something like
metadata
versus some other imported object which
just lists a couple of pieces of
metadata
like are those metadata keys to the
imported object or are they always going
to be in some other sub
element like you know metadata where are
you saying where is it
so so what you're saying is look the
basic point is
this is interpretable content that will
be the full name
probably of what we're currently calling
content would be
that part of the content that was
interpretable by us
or interpreted content
content would be fine and it seems like
you want something like
comments or or another property like
that
which is our understanding or our
label on this imported object as far as
we underestimated or or we created so
listen if
if one thing is raw content and one
thing is interpreted content yeah i see
that's not right because interpreted
content
suggests it's the whole of the raw well
if we say
partial content partial interpreted
content
or interpretable right
interpretable i think is better than
interpreted
right interpretable content that that
makes it fairly clear raw content
interpretable content
that makes it fairly clear it's not the
whole thing
um now
and i agree shoddy that we need some way
i know that's called comment
or comment is a very
uh common commonly used uh
name for formats when people want to put
free form
information i think we should i think we
should have that
but i think we need another thing as
well i think comment
is just random pieces of english text
okay
i think we need another thing which is
an association that can contain slightly
more structured information
maybe we call it information rather than
calling it metadata
because metadata suggests it's really
keyed into the
the um uh the content we just call it
quotes information
and that becomes that's an association
that has random gunk
that is information we were able to
forage from this subject
that makes sense to me what i'm
wondering at this point is if these keys
are standardized or if formats can just
willy-nilly put in
whatever they want as a key to imported
object i
suspect we're going to want uh additions
to
you know extra keys i i don't see it
immediately but i
i think it's likely but you know
alternatively
it would be inside the information
association then there's a sub key that
can give whatever you want
i mean that's the that's stage one
that will be my immediately i can see
that's useful
i have this feeling that it may get that
we may say oh we would like to put in
something you know
oh there's a case where we want the date
for example the creation
date well which which could be thought
of as generic i mean we could have
gradual increase in the generic pieces
where creation data is provided for
everything but not everything fills it
in
does that make sense so we could have
slow creep
of an increase of the generic ones where
formats that just don't know them just
say missing not available
sean what do you think so you're saying
every key that gets added would always
show up an imported object in the
formats that
don't implement them are just going to
say missing
no listen to what i'm saying okay i'm
saying
that the behavior that the for a
specialized format
you expect to put it under information
right there's a sub key of information
make sense okay so a particular format
expects some
list of keys that aren't always an
imported object and so for that format
it will always have that key and its
imported object
no that will have that key inside the
information
sub element of its imported object
okay okay now what i was then continuing
to say
is i can imagine that over time there
will be some
fairly generic additional properties
that we will see
that lots of of kinds of imported
objects want to have
for example owner creation date
those kinds of things okay yep
and i'm just saying i think we should be
open to adding some modest
number of those generic things
but we don't need to because we can
always put them under the information
uh you know properly see what i'm saying
in other words yeah and i think that's a
better place for them
well okay fair enough but i mean i'm
okay fine you know
let's discuss this again when we have
you know five or ten uses of imported
object
sure okay are we do we think
we have we've come to a conclusion here
that's reasonable
to anybody i mean i think i i think that
um
what we should look at and sean this is
kind of for you is
are there additional places now that we
have this pattern are there additional
places where we've
had to kind of import something into
some weird bite array
where we'd be better off
um just importing into this i think sean
needs to come back after now now that he
understands what
what this is supposed to be go look at
places we can use it
and then let's talk about this again
when we see those examples
make sense okay just
one comment uh fyi on the web this is
literally called
a blob that's that's what you have in
javascript basically to denote some
binary data together with a mime type
so you'd prefer that it'd be called
imported blob
or just blob no
we could call it the blob and uh you
know
invoke uh 50s sci-fi
i think it's not i mean blob is
yes i'm just i'm just no no no no no i'm
not i'm not talking about the blob i'm
talking about blob
instead of imported object imported blob
well you're worrying because you think
object has a handle but it doesn't mean
that in our system in many cases
i don't know anybody else supporting i
don't think blob is the right thing it's
cute but i don't think it's the right
thing
when i hear the word blob i think of the
database type
what the heck is that oh you mean
to put in a field of a database exactly
a very
large yeah right and
i mean we have lots we have lots of it
would be a good association right
i mean that's that's the right concept
yes oh okay
cool yeah that's the right concept
i mean we certainly have examples go
ahead we certainly have
um you know objects which are not
pointers right okay uh i'm not worried
about that
data object proof object time object
um look i like imported object for now
i i hadn't thought of the idea of blob
as an alternative name
um it's conceivable
let's let next iteration let's let shawn
inventory other places we might use this
so we don't just have one incredibly
obscure example
make sense definitely okay
good stuff thank you on to the next item
geometric assertion evaluation
oh boy you guys have all kinds of
difficult problems here
well it is lcc it's what we're here for
i know i know i know i know i know
you want us still around stephen uh no i
don't i don't think you know well who's
who's running this meeting who knows
what else is here
i i guess that would be me and i don't
think we need
sean and shawty unless and even yon i
mean jan might be a little bit
interested in the next item but
if he feels it's the
the not this one but the the function
for uh
well if john is able to stick around he
should otherwise um uh
that's fine i could stick around okay
all right
there okay but thanks shoddy sean uh
loom
departed yep thank you okay see ya
okay geometric assertion all right let's
um understand the horror here
should geo geometric assertion ever
evaluate on its own
ever so there will be an assertion like
these three points are collinear
is that correct right okay so now
normally when it's used it is a symbolic
use where it says geometric assertion
abc collinear correct right
correct but what if you fed in
literal objects there right or part
partial literal objects right right
even i mean there's some right so so so
there are three cases
there's the completely literal case
where it could conceivably evaluate
to true or false there's and then
there's the partial case where you have
you know two explicit points and a third
symbolic point and then maybe you want
condition right
so you have ax the list axa y
you know zero one one zero okay so
let's be concrete here so let's say
geometric assertion
is it the the assertion comes second
right
uh yes right
okay so if we say
um so we're saying points
is that right point you don't need
i just say abc
um right so if you're using this
outside of geometric scene it's not
going to evaluate unless you
i understand i understand that i
understand that i'm trying to understand
what we're talking about here
okay so that's one thing okay so now if
i put this
okay it evaluates right okay which
may or may not be a good thing um
okay um well okay so what's the question
then
so if i take something like this
and in principle i would love to be able
to do a reduce here
and be able to essentially solve for
what a has to be
so that this is true well so if you put
in a comma
b so you actually in uh
make it coordinates the networks i'm
sorry what do you mean a column b
as in here a b yes
and right well which is like
ambiguous somewhere between an
identifier because
because you haven't scoped the
identifiers here it's not inside a
geometric scene where you're declaring
abc are local identifiers
right it uh so that must be ambiguous
somewhere
or isn't it because because you don't
have things in lists
that there aren't cases where there can
be both a single object a
and a list a b i i think there are ian
aren't there uh i i
not i'm pretty sure there would be a bad
use of things
i guess i might be misinterpreting your
question but
outside of geometric scene if anywhere
there is
just a symbolic point so not
uh not a list of coordinates then it
does not evaluate
i understand what means is you're inside
the geometric scene
you have a point a and a radius a can
you
reuse the same simple immutable context
well no because i don't know but but but
are there k
are there assertions where it might be
and you just have a
is it ambiguous whether that's a point
coordinate and i think the answer to
that is yes
um yes but that's why you declare things
in geometric seasons i know
you don't declare them in naked
geometric assertion that's the point
right which which is why i think this
this other evaluation is problematic
that's what i would suspect too based on
that in other words
if you've scoped it and you've said
these are
symbolic things well at least we know
what to expect
now the fact is that some of these
operations like collinearity
you know it'd be really nice to be able
to have that as something that wasn't as
decorated as just as this whole
geometric scene thing
right and i think collinear i think will
linear write collinear points go linear
uh linear linear points right so so the
most important ones are in fact
becoming sort of
okay fine so in that case what does this
do
okay so it does auto evaluate
right which it should because right it's
uh
that's a computational thing i presume
if you gave it just an a it would just
sit there
but um
ah okay so i don't think that's
necessarily the right thing but but okay
hmm
i mean it could say x equals equals you
know it
could do a whole reduce like dance
okay so my comment is i agree with you i
don't think geometric assertion should
evaluate
i think that whether it is resolve
reduce
or what that evaluates it is not obvious
to me
right and and if you if you see the
bullet points it's sort of not
sorry adam let me just make the point
that it's not obvious to us
either as illustrated by my little
bullet point but yeah
uh so well i had to say i no no i think
it should be refined
actually so so refine is the the place
where you can add assumptions and
it evaluates to something so so then you
specify whether
whether you want a and b to be a real
number or a vector or whatever then it
if you give enough assumptions then it
will be able to
to give an explicit condition for
for for the generation i i quickly
forget about the function refine
but i'm not yeah i'm i mean i have to
say that my initial instinct having
having just heard this suggestion is
that that is exactly the right
uh thing because right so
right the problem with simplify is that
the leaf count of the result
may be much more than the leaf count of
the original expression
right yes that's not going to work
i mean simplify could be used but
you know we could we could support those
kinds of transformations in simplify
but there's no guarantee you'll get the
thing you want out
correct
um so look my gut instinct is don't have
it auto evaluate
have some function and refine maybe the
right one
that does it but make things like
simplify
aware of it now why is reduce
inappropriate for this
well it could it could use it
but uh but it's it's doing much more
than the new you might want to
okay well fine so refine is the refined
version and reduces the
is the kind of uh right yeah heavy
machinery
right yeah yeah i mean the only drawback
to reduce is if you just want to convert
it
to you know an equation
well reduce will convert it to equation
and then do a lot of work to super
simplify
that equation which may not be what you
want to
solve it and and you know if it can get
quite complicated quite easily the
equations you are getting from
geometrical
assertions so reduce may just go off and
never return
um nick asks the reasonable question
why is this the same function why is
geometric assertion the same thing
as the answer the question version
why isn't it like geometric query
i'm not sure i understand the question
the question is
geometric assertion would just not
evaluate yep
but there could be another function
let's say geometric query
that always evaluates
that asks the question is this true
huh um and then then the way it would
work is geometric assertion would be
able to be made to evaluate using refine
reduce whatever
but there would also be a geometric
query that just asks the question
well then we have then it's apply uh
[Music]
means what right well well then the
refine
or whatever are this other function
yes but i understand that but the fact
is that i understand that
on the other hand it's useful to have
some outer wrapper function that does
this
so geometric query will have assumptions
options so that you can
specify assumptions under which you want
to interpret uh
where i will create the assertion does
geometric assertion already have
um it just has does it have some weird
var args form
it does have a weird varags form
satisfy each of those properties it's
not too bad that that would not be
inconsistent with having assumptions as
well
except you can't have naked assumptions
it would have to be an assumptions
option
right
it's a little weird that we have those
properties as a
as a verags sequence
yeah i noticed that uh a couple of
months ago when i was
working with ian to clean up the
documentation
and i'm like i never um
i didn't quite understand that yeah and
the
the reason you need it right is because
a property can itself
be a list if it takes parameters
right also part of the thinking was
inside of geometric scene
you know this is kind of similar to
style and this is
um you know that's how style works
with the the var args um
yes okay one object and multiple styles
that you apply to it
okay so look if we think this is going
to be a common thing to do
we should probably think about this
geometric query thing if we think this
is an obscure case
in other words if what we think is we're
going to have things like colonial
points et cetera et cetera et cetera
that we're gradually going to
expose and functions all of the
non-trivial functionality here
then we should just let it be geometric
assertion and use things like refine
if on the other hand we think we're
going to leave in
the geometric assertion world a bunch
of um things which are
you know
much less um
yeah the the right of this type where
we're not going to promote them
then i think we should have geometric
query
so what do you guys think how many
properties are there
here they're quite a number yeah
and i am and we're not going to have
equilateral triangle q
i don't think right
or even regular polygon queue presumably
yeah i mean we have regular polygon
which is a representation transformation
is a wrapper around several different
transformations i'm not
why is that right i mean one thing
i think you you and our viewers should
be aware of is right
we have a version of this with uh
inside of geometric scenes so if you
construct a complicated geometric scene
or even a simple one
there's now a new property that you can
extract from it which is algebraic
formulation
which will take all of the properties
you have in there and turn them into a
into a formula right
i understand i mean geometric query
might suggest that you're actually going
to get an answer but it's okay if you
get something like a equals equals b
which is not yet resolved it's a
symbolic answer so to speak
all right i i i mean i'm i'm
liking next suggestion of a geometric
query
by the way i assume the other reason why
you've got verox is because you've got a
lot of listable
list list made properties
yeah yeah i wonder if something like
geometric
formula or geometric test might be a
better
name than query
kind of like query it's kind of asking
it well maybe i'm wrong but but i mean i
other use of query is something
um our geometric condition
it will give you the condition no
because a lot of times it's going to
answer true and false
it's the whole point i mean most of the
time people use this and they want to
know is this an equilateral triangle
boom they're not saying give me an
algebraic condition for it being an
equatorial triangle another
good thing about query is it
doesn't suggest that uh you should use
this inside of geometric scene so like
geometric condition you would think
this is a condition we can put inside
geometric ceiling geometric assertion
but
i think this is a winner okay um
also just to be clear since i'll be
implementing this
uh we still do want refine of geometric
assertion
to evaluate i think so and then reduce
and simplify and everything i mean it
should be
it should basically be a thing that this
is an
unevaluated form that our various
it can be considered a symbolic object
that can be manipulated by our symbolic
transformation functions
okay so do it for all of them i think so
i don't know about function expand
that's not so clear but but simplify and
reduce absolutely
okay and then i'm assuming if i plug
this into simplify
you would actually want simplify to run
on the uh on whatever algebra break
formulation it spits out
right um because
unfortunately it will also compare the
leaf comes to
to the original geometrical session so
it will do a do a lot of work and
probably return the geometrical session
back because it will
get yeah there's like a lot of times
these spit out real complicated stuff so
if you put it in the simplify and
actually run simplify on the
algebraic formulation it'll you know
take forever but um
um
i think that's the most we why don't we
just you know
play around with it and see how we feel
about it i mean i think we're all in
agreement that refined should just do
the obvious thing
and then we can you know simplify and
reduce we can
hook it up and see what happens and
decide whether or not we we want to keep
it
sorry what was the argument against
simplify doing something
and it may spend a very long time to do
nothing well
okay talking about the spend a long time
to do nothing i mean
we need to talk about using parallel
evaluation for simplify which simplify
is not currently doing right it's not
if you have multiple cores it's not
currently using them is that correct
no no well we should we should be using
parallel try and so on and we should
have
this is another topic we should have a
an option
that well yeah it's not right but except
you know right it's right you're going
down lots and lots and lots of possible
paths it's not
clear that you know where you'll right
how how to distribute and collect the
work
absolutely you don't know but but right
that's why parallel try
is the right thing right so it starts a
sub kernels
like automatically yes that's what
that's what i'm thinking
i think there should be an option that
causes it to do that
yeah i mean that's that's going to be
tricky though if right now now now we
now we return to the first topic in
today's meeting because
if the expression involves
lots of you know has dependencies that
are um have tentacles throughout the
system
then you're asking to distribute a lot
of definitions okay so let me tell you
something
i do this all the time i have about a
hundred cores i'm doing
tons of work that involves
parallelization okay
occasionally it blows up in my face but
usually it doesn't
okay in other words it is it is a you
know for something like simplifying an
algebraic expression
by the time the algebraic expression
you're simplifying is so complicated you
can't even distribute it to the
different cause
you know you you lost the game right
yeah i mean
right the the bigger concern is that you
know
it must either be off by default or it
must be easy to make off by
i agree i agree should probably be off
by default it should probably be off by
default but i think the important thing
is that
it should be doable because you know if
you've got a big complicated beefy
machine
or or network of machines it's really a
useful thing to be able to do
yep so you know and there's no way to do
it as a user right i mean you can't
the user can't get inside and do that
right i mean i guess i guess the first
step would be to support
parallelize of simplify and then
we can talk about options like the old
compiled
option in um in plot right this will be
parallelized arrow true or false
i'm not sure true well i think roman
would disagree with that but we can
get into the details once we once we
have something right
okay next item and we're going to have
to wrap up fairly soon
but i mean both of these are are
not critical this one's pretty short so
we could do this one and then skip the
last one let's try this one
um
yeah is it a possible identifier
well that's a little function to have
yeah so uh right so i think this is
maybe
from the user um but
um
[Music]
yeah i think this is from the user right
i mean
like i said i'm not sure that this is a
system function
um maybe it's a wolfram function repo
function
but it's certainly something we could
implement with brenton's stuff
i mean how how often do you
programmatically need to know if a
string is
well you know to test backtick foo a
string that might be in that
wfr for now okay and i think it should
be
um
the thing i don't like about symbol name
q is it suggests
is this the name of a symbol right
exactly yes i i i agree i agree that
that the name is wrong it's more like
valid identifier q
or possible symbol identifier queue
although that's very long
well we already have a notion of symbol
name don't we
uh symbol name is the function that
converts a symbol
to just to a string and of just the name
part minus the
context
uh right it should be a symbol
right and if you put a backtick in the
middle of that it would give you just
what's after the backtick
i see
well so that's a weird thing because
that's that's some
name is defining it the name to be the
beyond
context type thing so really it's like a
path what do we call that in the case of
url path
url
um
jan still here what is the i don't know
right
what's the question what do you call the
this is the whole path versus the end of
the path
the trait i would call that the trailing
path
i guess but
oops there's a distinction between the
domain name and the
the path but the path is still the whole
thing
okay whatever so it's not clear right
but right it's more like in file names
we have
what is it file there's file base name
and then file name take and so on
right so there's um
right but i mean the identity that that
we have
which you know we've had since v1 i
think right is that
the basically that the
you know context of symbol union
uh string join symbol name of symbol
is the
look why don't we just have a wfr
function valid symbol identifier queue
okay and um see whether that comes up
for promotion
later okay
okay so this is nothing
uh right so i
i had i mean this came up but somebody
one was complaining that somebody wasn't
in a usage
note and rather than doing the one-off i
asked ian to sort of take
a look at all of the related functions
that manipulate
symbols and and so we have a few
suggestions
but it's nothing pressing it's right
we've
we've been suffering this way since at
least v6 if not
v2 this is the question of whether we
should allow string named symbols
in these different places is that right
among other things yes
but that's the most uh right and i also
suggest de-documenting one thing
um
yeah yeah yeah like the the attributes
of hold pattern of symbol i just don't
understand that
what about attributes of hold of symbol
that seems more sensible to me
what right i mean you could always do
unevaluated if you were really
concerned about it a lot more convenient
to just map attributes across
hold of a bunch of held symbols well you
could also do two string
of uh no you couldn't because two string
evaluates
i mean it depends where you got it from
i i think attributes of hold of symbol
is useful because i think that
increasingly i mean so look
a big topic for me going forward is this
whole question
of of sort of execution traces of
programs
and sort of being able to after
attributes is hold all so there's no
problem
oh okay i'm going to throw out one
question here
which came up okay this is uh this is a
little brain twister
um from uh is actually from emerald
um they have the following issue
they have a function that's running in a
notebook
and uh the function
runs an experiment in the physical world
okay it's got you know it's got
thing thing thing and then it says okay
robot go and do this
that could take three hours then it goes
on with the code
chunk chunk okay
their issue is
how to maintain
some kind of frozen version okay what
they want to do
is to like freeze the notebook at the
point where it's
it's it's blocked running the experiment
they want to take this notebook that is
incense running it's in the middle of
execution
freeze it be able to store it somewhere
and rehydrate it when that experiment is
finished or be able to have somebody
go fetch a rehydrated version when the
experiment is finished
so in other words what it's doing is
it's interrupting the control flow
it's like you type input and you leave
the thing running
right you just type input but you didn't
type anything into the input
dialog and you want to be able to
store the notebook that comes out from
that
until until you've gotten around to sort
of external
let's say there was a url read there or
something
okay and that's a bad example again
something
an import how about this an import from
a dev
whatever a device and there was nothing
yet
to read from that device but there will
be
do you understand the issue do you
understand the framing of the problem
not really so like basically you want to
freeze the kernel state and put it in
like version control or something for an
arbitrary amount of time and then pull
it back out and
pick up where you left off kind of yes
let's try this again i think it i should
try to understand what this is
because this is a it's an interesting
i'm just sort of early stage thinking
about this problem
okay so here's the thing all right so we
say
let's say we have a func you know we
have something which says you know f
semicolon g semicolon
run experiment
h i okay
okay run experiment tells a robot to go
off and do something it takes three
hours
okay so the problem is
to think about what do we do in that
case so we want this notebook so one
possibility
is that this notebook it's like like for
example if you were running this
in a shell or something you could say
what is it control z or something what
what is the thing that puts it in the
background
that makes it um what do you call that
well you could i mean if if if
right i mean i if i understand now what
they're saying
right couldn't the first step of run
experiment be
you know notebook writes this save the
name
of the current notebook notebook closed
that notebook
and then the last step is notebook open
of the path to no because it isn't in
the right state it's not it's not in the
state where it's then going to evaluate
h and then i
uh i mean maybe we're thinking about it
wrong because maybe the way that this
has to work is
that this is i mean
it's like yeah i mean i i think i think
we would need john in this conversation
i don't know question right
maybe it's even mostly kernel question i
think it's
because it's not the same kernel that
keeps running all the time that's the
issue
oh right it's going to be rehydrated
maybe on a different machine even
right so what you say with emerald it's
it's very similar to ask function and
that they have the same problem there
that you you go to that function to that
form
fill parts in and then it asks you for
more input
and it has to go back and continue where
it left off how does that work though
it will ask i mean it's also a total
heck i think
carlo i think implemented that it it
basically
redoes the whole thing but it remembered
that
certain things were already filled in so
it kind of right
right right right right right that's
that's a key idea i think that that
to redo it knowing that the experiment
was already done
you see what i'm saying so rather than
thinking i'm going to freeze this
it's like no it's okay you can just
rerun it
because the other stuff is stateless you
can rerun it but this time through
it knows that the experiment is already
run and gives you the result
that seems a lot more consuming assuming
that the other stuff is all
deterministic
and that it's kind of cheap to do it
again i think that can work
well what's the alternative i mean the
alternative
i mean the alternative is like using
post
and you know storing stuff in the
initialization option of the notebook or
something
that's really horrifying but but i mean
the question is
what is the general case of what we're
seeing here okay
that's what i'm asking is this an
example of a pattern
that you know go off and do something
and then just i mean or see i'm trying
to understand is this like some
asynchronous task
you know for example let's say you ran
through this
it's got to exit it's got to not run h
and i
at this point it's got to say i've got
to this run experiment now i have to
stop
this is not nice a nice problem i mean
so it could be you know oh you don't
know how long the experiment is going to
take maybe it only takes five minutes
you're just going to leave that notebook
up but what if it doesn't what if it
takes three hours
i mean this is a micro batch job so to
speak
we understand sort of fire and forget
batch jobs that is
you're taking the whole function and
you're running it as a cloud submit or
whatever else
right and it just does its thing and it
tells you when it's done
this is something where you're
interspersing
the execution get what i'm saying
i just wondered if anybody had any ideas
about this
and again i suspect we're solving
slightly the wrong problem here
the the general question would be to
store the whole kernel state including
where its
execution state is right now right
right so marco unlocks he was mentioning
asynchronous run experiment no that
won't work the problem with that
is that yeah sure we can we can say
something like
you know uh local submit
of whatever it is you know pause of
seven or something that's just fine
but okay it'll make a task object
but then it will simply go on execution
here
after that local submit this would just
continue the execution there now
you know i do think we could absolutely
have some wrapper around this
see how would this work
it's a bit like continuation passing
style
in in computer science i feel like yes
it is
but but i mean that kind of thing
hmm
um okay there's a suggestion from ethan
here
tag the cells if they've been run to
encapsulate a notebook you could persist
by iconizing
all computed variables
i see what you're saying so in other
words if something has been successfully
computed
you include the output the problem is if
f and g don't have side effects that's
all good if they have side effects it's
much
messier
if they have side effects they suspect
that you're largely dead in the water
almost you know regardless of what
approach you take
yes
or it comes back to our first topic in
the meaning
on how to store definitions for things
yes and right well that that would be my
kind of define the current watermark so
to speak
if you've already done this and you
restart
and this is where you're going on from
so marco is commenting um
when done
i don't understand how when done do
stuff is
um uh
one done a b why isn't that just
equivalent to a semicolon b
yeah the problem here is not knowing
when the experiment has been done the
experiment can be run as an asynchronous
task that's fine
the difficulty is the control flow i
mean this is the thing i don't think
it's completely well defined what has to
happen here
you know it's like you're running the
notebook and even if you close the
notebook
it's still quotes running in the
background and if you reopen the
notebook
it somehow comes back to life what does
that mean
that's what it really is it's it's like
the what is it is it control z i haven't
done it for such a long time the
background's a job
like the ampersand at the end of a unix
shell script command
you understand what i'm talking about
yeah i think that's control z
right control c and then well then you
that stops it then you need bg
to release it into the bat right
it's running in the background but can't
you then pull it into the foreground
again
fg okay
and you know they really dug deep in
those early days of unix
work right you background it with bg and
you bring it into the foreground with fg
yeah yeah right
um
i don't yeah i mean i don't understand
enough
can you just yawn on somebody else
describe javascript promises
uh it's
it is it is to do something you know
asynchronous
uh the problem there is that there's
there is no blocking mechanism in
javascript
uh and i mean it's also a feature in a
sense
um so if if anything asynchronous
happens like
fetching a url request
uh you want to be able to see what
happens when that comes back
and uh for a long time that used to
happen just through callbacks you
probably
you know you give it a function that's
executed eventually
but and it's a nicer way to write that
is
is to have sort of a general agreed upon
concept to do
to to deal with um the
that promise thing so you can say
you know you you call a function that
returns a promise and then on that
promise you say it has a then
method and you say and there you specify
the callback
and then you can chain them and right
okay so so
the concept is in our task objects
a task object right now we just query it
and say are you done
what that will be saying is that it
calls back in and
automatically runs a piece of code when
it's finished
right somebody's typing we're hearing
uh typing typing typing
um
correct is that the analogous thing i
think you can do that with task objects
but it's not a common pattern right so
in other words
yeah it's certainly not so common in uh
languages like here where you have a way
to block things anyway and so you
yeah and no but but also i think it's
it's a different problem it's it's not
or it's not the whole thing that's
needed here no it's not
but it's an interesting mechanism anyway
that you know the question is
see the problem is what happens if
the process that initiated the task
object has gone away
how does it run where does it run
could you please mute yourself if you're
typing the
um how does it um
that that is a problem yeah we thought
about that at some point like you you
fire up the task
and then you restart your kernel
can you connect back to the task somehow
or how should that work
well right but no but can the task
connect back to the caller
that's the issue the caller what we
do with our tasks is it's a task goodbye
you can query the task et cetera et
cetera you can do a task wait if you
want to
to block on the task within a process
but
the task has no expectation that it can
send something back to its parent
yeah anyway okay we'll just have to keep
grinding on this i i'm pretty sure that
the frontal assault is not correct
that is the way to think about this is
what's really needed is something a bit
different
like for instance that you just say well
these are going to be different cells in
a notebook or something i i don't know
exactly what's needed
um or the whole thing is wrapped somehow
in something asynchronous
something like that i'm not sure um
uh let's see nick is suggesting
start with implementing hibernated
notebook that has a kernel state and
some initialization functions
i see i see i see i see um
and will is suggesting that the way of
thinking about a promise is it's a
container
for value that doesn't yet exist
that is a much better and and more
succinct
explanation i gave you
that's something we could have
that's interesting
so i mean that would simply be an object
whose value like date or something
changes or dynamic for that matter
i mean dynamic in a sense already does
has done that for
25 years or something um
it's a thing that gets its value from
elsewhere
it is a defined container for a thing
that gets its value elsewhere
in a sense uh
i mean dynamic also has the sort of
front-end versus kernel aspect
ingrained into it
no i understand but i mean in a sense
task weight
is like that it will do nothing well no
it'll block
oh i don't know okay requires more
thought let's think about nick's comment
here
about um hibernation notebook we have
thought about this we've thought about
dump save we've thought about doing this
in the cloud of being able to take a
cloud notebook
and hibernate it with its complete
kernel state
i mean i guess we've done experiments on
that years ago we did experiments on
that
um
[Music]
it's not a completely silly thing to
think about to be able and it also
relates to that first topic we were
talking about about full definitions
i mean in other words if you can save
your complete session
and then included in the notebook and
then rehydrate from that
that's an interesting possibility
we should talk about that case we should
talk about that that's an interesting
thing that we've thought about
at different times over the years we
talked about it for the cloud yarn do
you do you i mean i'm
kind of thinking that might even have
been amazingly before your time that we
talked about that seriously
it was before i was
yeah overseeing the whole thing so i
wasn't directly involved for that so
but i think it was constantine oh
horrendous
experience i think that might be right
maybe we should get a report on what
actually happened there
i think it wasn't i think the problem
was that the idea was
you know what if somebody walked away
from their cloud notebook
and came back the next day
and wanted to start typing again
you know if we've if our if you know
we don't want to leave a kernel
allocated to that person for a day a
week a year
so to speak but we solved that problem
in other ways
and we also decided it wasn't that
important a problem to solve
but um but that would be the mechanism
is is to dump save
the kernel let's can we put that on i
guess
probably in is it an ece meeting agenda
to talk about that
um okay we've got a couple more comments
in then we should wrap this up
marco terminating condition of task
on close
i have some function when done
yeah the problem is where do you run the
terminating condition
that's the difficulty
i see when done
when done on this terminating condition
yeah the terminator condition
it simply needs to be
i see i see i see i see but the yeah the
when done thing that we can achieve that
with task weight i believe that's just
basically task weight
um
ethan is saying the main issue is lost
progress and state from crashes or
missing inputs caching the progress of
how far it got
is what people want
yeah i mean the difficulty there is you
know maintaining the stack state and so
on is really
complicated
um
yeah kobe observes
frozen sequence on the outcome it
generates the same external calling yeah
i mean this is complicated it's a
complicated mess all right i just wanted
to raise this
um we're getting a few thoughts here
but uh let's talk about hibernated
kernels another time
okay anything else for right now
nope okay thanks everybody thanks to
folks on the live stream
thanks for the suggestions much
appreciated